the most comfortable way into the
berchtesgaden national park leads over
lake koenigsegg
one of the electric boats takes you to
the herschel peninsula here at an
elevation of 600 meters above sea level
stands this mountain lakes main landmark
st bartholomew's church a place of
pilgrimage
right next to it is a restaurant with a
beer garden
it's a great place to stop for a bite
and let first impression sink in
you can sit on the boat let everything
slide past and go into raptures
it's gorgeous breathtaking i can't find
words for it
if you enjoy a challenge you can take a
climbing route into the only german
national park in the alps
the mountain guides show participants
how to secure themselves properly
because for many it's their first
attempt at rock climbing
the route takes you up mount gruenstein
1 306 meters high
at difficult passages there are helpful
hints like whether to go right or left
this case bear right
then the root leads over a chasm meter
by meter towards the summit after three
hours the group have reached their
destination
it's left a few marks but generally i
coped with the altitude better than i'd
expected to
the village of ober salzburg is part of
berges garden
under nazi rule it was the most
important center of power after berlin
hitler spent a third of his time as
chancellor here in ober salzburg
the dark chapter in germany's history is
dealt with in a documentation center
hitler had already come here as a
tourist in the 1920s and built out the
village into a seat of government after
taking power and expelling the local
residents
here the nazi leaders planned their
crimes but they also vacationed
a great number of people who come here
in summer as tourists don't want to deal
directly with the nazi past
they want to look through the keyhole
into hitler's private life
how he lived what he was like in private
what was his relationship with eva braun
that's why they
that seems to appeal to people
the extensive bunker complexes some of
the few remaining structures from the
nazi era show that over salzburg was no
carefree holiday paradise
kale shine house known in english as the
eagle's nest has remained unscathed
here display panels describe its history
from its building by the nazis to
liberation by the allies
the panoramic view from 1834 meters is
unchanged and still impressive
you can't explain this view until you're
standing here it's
beautiful it's amazing it's breathtaking
from up here you have everything in your
sights from lake koenigsegg to the
vatsman the peak that towers above
everything in the bestest garden alps